greetings everyone and welcome this is
Rob Sanders from simply learned and
today we're gonna go over date a studio
so buckle up and let's get going with
some data studio from Google and so the
first thing you'll need is a Google
account okay so if you have a Google
account if you're able to get an
analytics or Google Ads
then you should be able to use that same
email address to get into data studio
and all you really have to do is just go
to data studio google.com or you could
just Google stay in a studio and get the
link but if you're using your same email
address you should be able to get into
data studio and when you're in data
studio you'll be able to see some
templates at the top that you can work
with when you're setting up a report or
you'll be able to see some existing
reports that you have either set up or
somebody has shared with you okay so
here if you just click on shared with me
I'll be able to see all the different
reports that have been shared with me in
the past okay so here if I click on
recent I could see all the reports that
have recently opened so let's just take
a sneak peek at one of those reports so
if I open up a report that I actually
created then what I'm going to be able
to do is look at some data over a period
of time just like I would if I was in
Google Analytics okay so the great thing
about data studio here is that it works
just like any Google Drive document
whether it be Google sheet a Google Doc
or a Google slide okay you could share
the document with anybody you choose to
anybody with a Google account okay or if
you just want to share a link okay you
could just click on convey or edit copy
the link and then you can message that
person or email that link to whomever
you want to see this report okay if you
want to invite somebody to edit it or
just view it you can
certainly just type in their name or
email address so that's the great thing
right off the bat with data studio is it
shareable so if multiple people have
added access to the same report then
multiple people can go ahead and edit
that report even at the same time so
that's the great thing about data studio
we're gonna cover a lot of different
benefits to data studio I definitely
like using data studio over analytics
and since we're talking about the
comparing the two this in my opinion
replaces if I go to analytics and I go
to say customization and I go to
dashboards this replaces the old
dashboard reports and if you see here at
the top Google even persuading you to
move over to data studio because
dashboards and custom reports are very
limited in nature whereas data studio
not limited at all okay you basically
are creating reports that suits your
needs so just continuing on with some of
the top-level
key benefits to data studio is if we
like a report we see we can easily just
make a copy of it so I have to do is
click on that copy and I'm just gonna
copy over everything over so I'm going
to copy the data sources or I can change
the data source and basically what we
mean by data source is where is Google
pulling the data from now keep in mind
and I'll go over this more specifically
with data studio you can pull pretty
much data sources from anywhere in any
source whether that be a spreadsheet a
database another Google product another
platform like Facebook you could
certainly pull it from analytics so you
could pull data from any data source so
if you go ahead and make a copy you just
have to make sure you know what data
source you're pulling the data from
because basically all this is is report
with dimensions and metrics and those
metrics are data points associated with
that dimension so we could certainly
refresh data okay again we can get the
report link just by clicking on the
report link and copying it it's a bit of
a shortener here I can go ahead and
schedule an email delivery so if
want to go ahead and have this report
sent to somebody I can certainly do that
here and I can have it sent to them
either daily weekly or monthly and then
you can also download the report so if
you download the report okay I can
choose all pages or select specific
pages so in this report I have two pages
set up now in data studio you can have
as many pages as you want okay so here I
could choose just one page okay some
additional options I can add a link back
to the report I can password protect the
report okay I can ignore the custom
background color if I wanted to I'm just
gonna go ahead and download that and I'm
gonna download it in PDF and so when it
downloads I'm gonna be able to then you
know view this report or send it off in
PDF format and so those are some of just
the top level features that you have
available to you in data studio now
let's take a step back okay this is if
you're just viewing the report and you
want to share it or download it or send
a link to somebody what if you actually
want to create one so that's what I'm
gonna walk through here I'm going to go
ahead and create one now remember we can
just go ahead and copy this if we like
it we can copy it we could choose
certainly choose different sources of
data so I'm gonna go ahead and just play
around and choose different sources of
data I don't know exactly what those
sources are but I'm gonna go ahead and
choose them anyway then I'm gonna go
ahead copy that report so I copied it
and basically what it's gonna give me is
a duplicate of that report except the
data is going to be different because
I'm choosing different data sources okay
so now here we can see the report and
it's going to load up and it's going to
load up with different data sources now
if I don't see any data that means the
data sources I chose don't have any data
that aligned with those specific metrics
and dimensions and that's exactly what I
see here so what I'm gonna have to do is
go ahead and choose different data
source so let me select a different data
source here I'm gonna go ahead and
choose that one or I can go ahead and
create a new data source so let me just
do that
so I'm gonna click create new data
source and now if I don't want to use
one that I've used in the past I can go
ahead and choose from all these
different data sources available to me
so there's no limit on what we could
connect so you see bigquery SQL ok you
can see data from Google's marketing
platform display video 360 Google
Analytics Google sheets Google search
console ok keep scrolling down basically
what data studio does is partner with
third-party products like super metrics
for example so that super metrics is the
intermediary plot program that pulls in
for example Facebook ads or Google my
business pulls it into Data studio for
you here you can see Adobe Analytics ok
you have all sorts of connectors that
you can connect to so I could choose any
one of these to connect it now if I
choose one would say super metrics I'm
going to need that super metrics account
now if you choose any one of these
direct Google connectors like I'm gonna
choose Google Analytics then you don't
need a third-party intermediary like
super metrics you can go ahead and based
on the login that you have set up or
that you're using the login to data
studio you're gonna be able to see all
the other Google Analytics accounts you
have access to so I'm just going to go
ahead and choose an account here I'm
gonna choose a property and I'm going to
choose my view then I'm gonna click
connect ok so that's how you basically
will connect a new data source now when
you actually connect that data source
what's going to happen is data studio is
going to give you the option and it's
gonna give you an option to make changes
to all the dimensions available
dimensions are in green and if I keep
scrolling down I can have the
opportunity to change any of the metrics
metrics in blue and I can change it to
the type of metric I'm getting whether
it be just a numeric or currency
okay or I can change it to aggregate
Auto I can change it the description of
it
okay that's making changes to something
I can even just delete it or remove it
or I can go ahead and add my own metric
or dimension
okay just by clicking on add in a field
and so here I'm going to go ahead and
choose some available fields or put in
my own formula so this is kind of that
first step when you create your source
or your second step if you will your
first is actually choosing the source in
this case we chose Google Analytics the
second step is having the opportunity to
change out or edit or add dimensions and
metrics now if you're a novice or
beginner to data studio then I would say
let's skip this step if you're not
comfortable editing or adding dimensions
and metrics and go ahead and just skip
it and click on this blue call-to-action
add to report okay so I'm gonna add it
to the report and now that it's been
added now I'm still seeing no data why
am I seeing doneita so if you copy
report you don't see any data chances
are it probably has a filter because I
copied it and here you can see I have a
filter so I'm just gonna go ahead and
remove the filter and voila
I see data so that's something you need
to be aware of when you actually copy
over an existing report you have to
choose the status source but keep in
mind you when you copy over an existing
report you're also copying over filters
and segments so if you're familiar with
Google Analytics you know that in Google
Analytics if I go back in analytics here
and let's just say I go to acquisition
and I go to all traffic and I go to
channels what do I have the opportunity
to do in these standard reports well I
have an opportunity to add a segment I
also have an opportunity to add a table
filter
you could do the same thing in data
studio okay because I copied the report
basically I copied over all of those
filters table filters and segments that
go along with it and so you just need to
be cognizant that as you're building out
this report now that's if I copied it so
you can see I copied it and everything
else that goes along with it the color
scheme the the logo etc now this is if
you not familiar data state it's good to
copy report play around with it etc
that's probably what I would recommend
so again if you're not familiar with
days to you want to get comfortable and
go ahead and she even choose one of the
templates if you don't have access to an
existing report so let's go ahead and
just choose I'm gonna say one of these
templates that data studio is provided
okay you can see looks pretty good
layout looks pretty clean I got all my
important metrics in here what's gonna
happen is if I want to use it I'm gonna
click use template now same thing that
occurred when I copied a previous report
I'm gonna have to choose a data source
so I don't want to choose Google
Analytics sampling of data or sample set
of data I want to choose some actual
data so I'm gonna have to go in and
choose an existing I could choose an
existing data source here or I can
connect to a new data source okay so
let's go ahead and just choose one of
these data sources I already have access
to and I'm gonna go ahead and copy this
template so it works in the same way as
if I copied an existing report I'm just
copying a template okay so here you can
see I'm copying the template now okay
the only thing that's missing here is
the ability for me to edit the
dimensions of metrics so if you could
anytime you add a new data source you're
always going to be prompted to have the
ability to edit dimensions and metrics
if you don't if you're not comfortable
with that then just go ahead and add the
data source just like I've done here
and so now I could see basically the
same report I could just see it's just
pulling in data from a different data
source that's all now I'm in edit mode
okay so if I want to view the report
just as anybody else would view it if
you gave them a link to view it I'm
gonna click on this view button here and
so now I can see up some dropdowns here
and so this drop-down is basically
allowing me to choose my own Analects
account if I wanted to so I can go ahead
and just choose any one of these if I
wanted to change the data here I got
another pull down and this is my date
range selector so I can change the date
range if I want to do so if I change the
date range then the data is going to
change now if I want to edit anything
here in this report I'm gonna have to go
back and click on the edit mode so just
click on the edit button there and now
I'm gonna be able to go in and edit this
existing template now I've already
established a data source but I could
change the data source if I want to all
I have to do is just go here click on
any one of these tables or metrics and
change out the data source just by
clicking on this icon here okay where it
says edit data source so I'm gonna have
the ability to make changes to any of
the dimensions and metrics or I could
just get rid of that data source and
choose a new data source now in data
studio you have the option to change the
layout you have the option to change a
theme so you can go from a simple theme
to say a simply dark theme you could
change any aspect of the report if you
want to so just know that anytime you
click on any of the data points you have
the same options available you have a
chance to edit the data or you have a
chance to style it so when we talk about
styling you know you can basically add
labels you can hide labels you can
compact the numbers you can style it any
way you want based on the particular
table and so that's the great thing
about DSTV is really really customized
to what you need
so for example here what are the top
countries by sessions well I don't have
to show legend if I don't want so I'm
just gonna get rid of the legend it
could change the font okay I can change
the color scheme on it I can go ahead
and do a lot of different things here
so once I've made changes after I view
it I'll be able to see those changes in
full effect
okay so just know that in data studio
whatever report you're looking at that
you have edit access to you have the
ability to make changes to anything in
that report now here you can see I see a
lot of different data great what I can
actually do too is add a page and so
let's go ahead and click on add a page
and now we have two pages to our report
and now I have a blank canvas on page
two so now what do I want to put on page
two well the best practice to me is
organizing your data okay so just like
in analytics analytics organizes their
data between audience acquisition
behavior and conversions as a best
practice that's probably what I would do
here maybe stick all your mobile on page
or your acquisition on one page or your
maybe your organic search on one page
now it's okay to have a summary page
just like we have on page one but if
you're going to have multiple pages then
perhaps think about organizing it based
on the multiple pages that you add so
here let's go to page two blank canvas
so the great thing about data see you
again just very easy to start populating
okay so I'm gonna go ahead and click add
a chart okay which type but sharp I want
to add well in the spirit of
visualization you probably always want
to choose something visual start with an
easy pie chart here I'm gonna go ahead
and select the pie chart and I'm gonna
place it to where I want okay I know I
can go ahead and increase the size if I
want to make it smaller make it bigger
etc voila I have a cloud char now if I
want to edit this pie chart again I have
my options available I have my data and
I have my style so I know it's pulling
from this data source here okay I want
to change my dimension dimension is what
we're measuring so let's just maybe
change it to source and maybe I want to
go from page views - let's just say goal
conversions so I can just go in and
start typing in the metric and here I
could see goal conversion rate let's
choose that okay now I can see source by
goal conversion rate now if I don't want
source let's change that back to the
fault channel grouping so now my
dimension is default channel grouping by
goal conversion rate so now if I'm
looking at my data I could see that
referral has a 51.8% goal conversion
rate followed up by organic search with
19.5%
ok so again it's very easy to edit the
data points on any chart now if I want
to style it I'm just gonna click on
style here I can go with a single color
dimension values okay I can slice it up
in different colors I could choose a
background color can data boarder
customization is really endless here I
can change it from 10 to say 12 slices
if it's available maybe go down to the
top three it's as easy as it gets I mean
it really is fairly intuitive to use you
just gotta learn what dimensions and
metrics you want to use now I have my
pie chart the great thing about data
studio just like PowerPoint for example
I can go ahead and just copy this pie
chart command C then command V and
wallah I now have a copy of it okay well
maybe I don't want to pie charts so let
me go ahead and change one so I can go
ahead my upper right here and go from
say a pie chart to let's just say a
trend line if it makes sense or maybe a
combo chart so I have my sessions along
and my goal conversion rate now I can
again go ahead and change that I don't
want sessions maybe I want you know go
completions or something so let's go
ahead
add that in there go completions so now
I can see go completions and then go
conversion rate by my default channel
grouping so again I could style it you
know if I don't want red bars I can go
ahead and choose a different bar okay
it's really that simple now if you find
you're running out of real estate okay
you can always scroll down and change
the height so if I change it from 1200
to fall to 1800 pixels I can get more
real estate to work with likewise on the
width so now I can make it really wide
to work with now when you make those
changes to the page you're probably
going to see the same effect happen on
page 1 fact you will sit back to page 2
okay so if we get a page 2 here what we
could do is go ahead and add more charts
or we can copy and paste existing charts
and go ahead and change them up ok just
by command C and command V now what you
want to do if you create more pages here
is maybe add in your date range so if I
go click on my date range symbol here
I'm just gonna drag and drop that
enlarge it a bit now I can make it a
fault date range I can say I want to
show data for this month so anytime
somebody goes to the page the data that
shows is going to be for the month the
month today now again if you want to
customize it what you can do is you can
just copy and paste so control C or
command C go back to page 2 command V so
this gives you the ability to just start
customizing them the one drawback to
data studio being a little bit nitpicky
is in PowerPoint if you're copying from
slide to slide it tends to paste it in
the same exact location I know it sounds
a little bit nitpicky but in data studio
and you copy and paste something it
doesn't necessarily always paste it in
the exact location so I've noticed that
being the issue but it's a small issue
nonetheless so you have the ability to
copy an existing report you have the
ability to go ahead
and choose an existing template and like
I said going back to data studio you
have the ability to just start with a
blank canvas
so again just walking you through the
steps here blank report brand new canvas
I need to choose a data source so you
can see existing data sources if you
don't have existing data sources to
choose from you can always just click
create new data source okay when you
create new data source you're gonna
choose from a list if you're new to of
data studio's start with something easy
like Google Analytics if you choose
Google sheets then great you're gonna be
asked to look for data in Google sheets
like wise or Google Ads if you choose
Google Ads you're gonna have to choose
at Google Ads account so start easy
start with Google Analytics Kenny I'm
gonna choose analytics I'm gonna choose
my account my property I'm gonna choose
my view I'm gonna go ahead and connect
because this is a new data source I have
the ability to go ahead and edit my
existing dimensions and metrics if I
want I don't have to then I'm gonna go
ahead and click Add to report it's gonna
confirm the connection to the data
source now I have my connection to my
data source
I am frayed start doing what I need to
do to the report whether that be get
somebody else involved immediately by
sharing it with them go ahead and start
adding pages and organize it in you know
adding my date range adding a logo
adding a logo is simply just clicking on
image selecting my phone or my images
it's the best practice anytime you
create a table I would go ahead and put
a text box above it maybe put a title so
you could say channel in this case
channel by conversion rate okay so let's
make that a little bit bigger as the
best practice that's what I would do now
it's you free to do whatever you want in
data studio the whole point of data
studio is really to customize the report
any way you want and what I mean by
customized is adding the dimensions and
metrics that are important to you and so
data studio gives you the opportunity to
copy an existing report or again
you can use existing template or start
with a bike report the options are all
there for you data state is fairly easy
to use again you could share it okay you
can download it you can schedule emails
you can send a link to people
okay there's really no limit to what you
can do with data studio okay again you
can rearrange things at pages organize
them add filters hats segments I mean
basically anything you can do in
analytics
you can do in data studio a lot more
features my recommendation to get
started you know go ahead and choose
that blank canvas and just start playing
just start playing by adding sharps okay
once you add charts
okay the data is gonna populate and
again you just then free to start
playing around with dimensions and
metrics so that's the way to get started
with data studio practice makes perfect
once you get more comfortable then
you're gonna have full fledge reports to
work from just like I use for my clients
there's no limit on what you can do and
what you can see and again customization
makes a report look good obviously the
data and improve data is going to make
your report look good as well so keep
all those things in mind apply some of
the best practices but more importantly
play around get comfortable and then
eventually you're gonna start using data
studios your main source of data over
Google Analytics so I want to thank you
for hanging in there have fun with data
studio if you have any comments or
questions or best practices or things
that I didn't mention in today's webinar
go ahead and add them to the comment
section below this video to be more
information please visit us at simply
learn com thank you again and I'll see
you soon
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here